certains croient que le premier mutant est
né il y a des milliers d'années au moins
quand il ressuscite l'apocalypse est né
il y a des millénaires et il a apporté la
civilisation à l'humanité mais à son tour
croyait qu'il était un dieu pocalypse
s'est rajeuni à travers l'
histoire en prenant le corps d'un autre
nouveau  s'accorder avec chaque mutant qu'il habite, il
prend leurs pouvoirs donc il a acquis pendant des
milliers d'années de multiples pouvoirs pour
nous contrôler tous
vous êtes tous mes enfants et vous avez perdu
se réveille en 1983 dans un monde qui pour
lui est une civilisation géante corrompue pour
avoir un  acteur brillant comme Oscar Isaac
incarner la villa apporte une complexité très puissante
au personnage l'
apocalypse a décidé de prendre le jugement
du monde alors il a réuni une équipe
de mutants tout ce qu'ils ressentent c'est
nous tous contre un dieu allons à la guerre
x-men  l'apocalypse est de loin le plus grand
film x-men les pouvoirs du méchant sont
beaucoup plus grands et les enjeux sont beaucoup
plus élevés